- Good morning, Believe
Nation, my name is Lily,
and my one word is extraordinary.
I live to encourage people
to be extraordinary,
so together we can make this
world an extraordinary place.
So to help you on your
journey, today's message is
attack over to you, John Jocko Willink,
(rooster cawing)
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me going
- One of my direct subordinates,
one of my guys that worked for me,
he would call me up or pull me aside
with some major problem,
some issue that was going on.
And he'd saw, boss we got this
and that and the other thing.
And I'd look at him and I'd say, good.
And finally one day he was
telling me about some issue
that he was having, some problem,
and he said, I already know
what you're going to say.
And I say, well what am I going to say?
He said, you're going to say good.
He said, that's what you always say.
When something is wrong and going bad,
you always just look at me and say good.
And I said, well yeah.
When things are going bad,
there's going to be some good
that's going to come from it.
Didn't get the new high
speed gear we wanted?
Good.
Didn't get promoted?
Good, more time to get better.
Oh, mission got canceled?
Good, we can focus on our other one.
Didn't get funded?
Didn't get the job you wanted?
Got injured, sprained my
ankle, got tapped out?
Good.
Got beat?
Good, you learned.
Unexpected problems?
Good, we have the opportunity
to figure out a solution.
That's it, when things are going bad,
don't get all bummed out,
don't get startled, don't get frustrated.
If you can say the word
"good," guess what?
It means you're still alive.
It means you're still breathing.
And if you're still
breathing, well then hell,
you still got some fight left in you.
So get up, dust off, reload,
recalibrate, reengage.
And go out on the attack.
- So I think too many
people dwell on the bad,
and not on the good.
They get so consumed about the
current situation they're in
and they complain,
without realizing that
they could do so much more.
I think about my situation,
I grew up really poor.
I slept on the floor in a tiny
room that my parents rented.
I wasn't able to go on
any trips with my friends.
I wasn't able to buy the fancy clothes.
I was made fun of because
my pants were too short.
But you know what, I'm grateful.
I'm grateful for all those experiences.
Because it made me who I am today.
I wouldn't be 25% of the person I am today
if I hadn't gone through
all those hardships.
I wouldn't have known how to
work hard, to be resourceful.
I know the pain and
the struggle that comes
from not having money, and
it made me work so hard.
I would wake up every Saturday
when I was 13 years old
at 5am so I could go
work a waitress shift,
while everybody else slept.
I knew everything I wanted
wasn't going to be given to me.
I knew I had to work hard for it.
So everything that I do today,
whether it's a job that I want,
the business I want to create,
being in front of the camera
right now, it's all hard work.
And nobody sees that,
people see the opportunities
that I've given to people,
but they don't see the hard
work that goes behind it.
So next time you find yourself
complaining about something,
you not having the right equipment,
not being the right gender,
not being the right color,
not having the right contacts,
think about what is right
about you and focus on that.
Because that's your strength.
That is what's going to make
you grow and become stronger,
and that will make you unique
and become the person you are.
So next time you're facing
a difficult situation,
think to yourself, "good" and attack.
So the question of the day is,
what is the bad situation
you're dealing with right now?
So leave it in the comments below,
and I'll join in on the discussion.
I also have a quick shout
out for Andy Duinker.
Thank you so much for picking up a copy
of Evan's book, "Your One Word."
Your support means a lot to us
and we hope you're enjoying the read,
So thank you so much for watching,
we believe in you and hope
you continue to believe
in yourself and whatever your one word is.
And we'll see you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of espresso.
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me going
(typing)
- If there's anything in life
that you don't currently have right now,
it's because of who you
are and how you think.
Come on, right now, you saying
ET man, you talking to me.
Man, I'm going through some type of pain,
I'm ready to quit and give
up, let me see your hand.
Something in life, I'm ready
to quit on, give up on.
Come on, raise your hand high.
I'm ready to quit on, I'm
ready to give up on it,
come on raise it up.
Alright, what I need you to do is
I need you to find a reason to keep going.
And if you can find a
reason to keep going,
I know you're strong enough to do it.
Cause you human, and every
human has what it takes
to get past whatever they going through
if they decide to.
Push through it, push through it.
Tragedy and trials come to everybody.
Only the strong survive.
I watch my wife when she got diagnosed,
I watched my wife have terrible days.
And she probably missed two days of work
the whole time she had MS.
I watched her go to work and I'm like,
boo, why in the world would
you get up and go to work?
You don't even need the money.
Why would you do it, it's cold.
It's 10 degrees in Michigan
and your MS flare up when
it's cold, what are you doing.
She said, I can't see my daughter,
I can't have my daughter see me weak.
Cause my daughter going
to be married one day,
and my daughter going
to face tragedy one day,
and I have to show her how to do it.
So I get up and get dressed,
and I go to work every day,
so my baby girl can know
how to get through trials.
Cause one day she ain't
going to be under our roof,
and she going to have to do it alone.
And I don't want to talk,
I want to model what it looks like.
My daughter got on the prayer line,
she could pray me another
day, told her testimony,
she's like, I didn't even
feel like going to school,
I didn't feel like walking
a mile to go to class.
And I thought about it, my
mom got a chronic illness.
My mom, in her 40s, could
get up with a chronic illness
and go to work, why surely I can get up
at 18 years old and go to class.
It worked, it worked, it worked!
Listen to me very closely, you
all running from obstacles,
when in fact it's the obstacle
that's going to take
you to the next level.
Like you all running from pain,
you all running from challenges.
You telling me how difficult your life is,
do you understand it is the difficulty
that's going to prepare you and
take you to that next level?
Why do you keep crying, why me, God?
Why did I get MS, why did I get cancer,
why did my mama die, why did I get fired?
Do you understand, list
you got through that,
you got put through that,
because what that does,
that tension produces greatness.
Stop running from it and run to it.
Come on you all, you all got to hear me.
The reason why you do what you do
is more critical than what you do.
And if why you do what you do is weak,
I need you to go back
and start all over again.
Because if your reasoning is weak,
you're not going to get it done.
Why, because life is going
to beat you upside your head.
And I'm going to tell you this,
I don't care who you are
and what profession you in,
before you blow up, life
will strip you to the core.
But if you weak, you will be broke.
And I'm not here because I'm the best.
I'm here because they tried to
break me, and they couldn't.
- Guy just hit me on Snapchat and said,
hey man, I'm going for it cause
I only got one life to live.
And I Snapped him back and just said,
hey man, what if that one
life thing isn't true, bro?
And now he's wondering, he's like,
what you mean, man, what you mean?
I said, well here's the deal, okay?
I mean you don't know
and I don't know, right?
I mean maybe you don't
know, and maybe I do.
But here's the deal.
I'm much more dangerous and
much more of a risk taker
and much more a go-it-all-the-way
dude and less introverted
when I'm not worried about
the one life myth, okay.
I'm thinking, hey baby,
what if I live forever, man?
Then am I willing to take the risk,
am I willing to make the sales call?
See, me living forever,
the immortality concept,
makes me way dangerous,
makes me sick dangerous,
makes me crazy dangerous, okay.
It makes me want to go for
it every freaking single day
because I don't have the ultimate to lose.
You understand what I'm saying?
Hey, check it out, maybe you know,
maybe you don't know,
but I bet you're curious.
What if you live forever?
What if this like the thousandth time?
What if you've got a thousand
more runs at this deal?
Well then go for it.
Bottom line is one life or many lives,
go for it today, go for it in a big way,
and go for it like you
going to live forever.